so Riverdale the final season when you
just went back to work stepping on set
did it feel different than all the times
before it does it does it has a
Bittersweet feeling to it and I think
I'm kind of just trying to approach this
season with uh not taking anything for
granted really trying to be present
trying to enjoy my co-stars so it is
it's different for me at least I love
that you say trying to embrace your
co-stars and just having fun you know
the tick tocks the three of you together
how much do we need to be paying you for
this stuff we found out today that we
were nominated for a streamy award I
don't know what that is but yes I was
like hey man it's what we do to
entertain ourselves on set and now it's
just funny we we laughed at it like in a
very oh that's sweet kind of way well
they're hilarious and I have to know as
the show comes to a close will The Tick
Tock account live on
I mean we're all going to be going in
such different directions like location
wise that I hope that when we do hang
out and come together we can find a way
to make a tick tock yeah 100 and have
you thought about what from the set
you're planning to steal or what what of
Betty's wardrobe you want
I'm not allowed to take the Wardrobe no
no no I mean I can steal something I
don't know I you know I don't want to
hoard anything I have literally the
episodes The 100 plus episodes that I've
done I don't need anything physical I'm
taking the experience with me and as you
take that experience and you step into
your next chapter I know you've got a
production company and that's got to be
really exciting what is the kind of
content that is gonna come next for you
well my production company has been
really focused on telling uh modern
stories we we think that media right now
is not exactly catching up to the real
world and doesn't accurately reflect how
young people feel and since I'm such a
big mental health Advocate we want to
focus on telling those kinds of stories
and also queer and inclusive stories and
hiring as many women writers and
directors as possible I love that yeah I
have to tell you I just read your
interview in I believe it was Hunger
magazine and you said something really
striking to me you said you really hate
the word famous and you hate the word
celebrity I'm curious how do you as an
actress balance being a public figure
when you know there is so much interest
in your personal life
it's it's interesting because I am such
an open book and so I'm like what are
boundaries but um I think it's sort of
taking it on honestly like an interview
by interview basis and see if I feel
like opening up I will and I know that
certain parts of my life that I want to
protect at this point and and I do a
good job of doing that but I think uh
I'll always be willing to talk about the
subjects that a lot of people maybe
are too afraid to do so and I would hope
that it kind of sets an example for
others to join in the conversation for
sure what did you make of the reaction
to you talking about the Met Gala do you
really want to go back
um you know it's an honor to be asked to
go I think uh I would love to go again I
I think I would love for everything I
say about it to stop being an article
but um but I'm very I'm very fortunate
that I've been able to go for three
times that's an honor so you know would
love to be welcomed back but understand
if if not my last question for you I
love how outspoken you are I have to
tell you your bravery is something to be
admired putting yourself out there is
not easy in this moment in this era of
lily as you kind of say goodbye to
Riverdale and step into your next
chapter what do you want your fans to
know
I think I want my fans to see me as as
as a serious actor I think that's why
I'm here that's why I entered this
industry because my heart is really in
acting and I'm just a performer and the
advocacy kind of just came along for the
ride and I'm so happy that it did but I
really want to sink my teeth into
beautiful storytelling and I hope that's
how people start to see me
oh